قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
البنتاجون باتريك رايدر ان الولايات
المتحده ليست ضعيفه حيال تهديدات الحوثيين
في البحر الاحمر وخلال مؤتمر صحفي اضاف
المتحدث ان هناك عواقب لهجمات الحوثيين في
البحر الاحمر وينبغي اخذ التصريحات
الامريكيه بالخصوص على محمل
الجد ينضم الينا من البنتاجون مراسل
الجزيره فادي منصور دعنا في سياق هذا التص
ريح الخاص بالبحر الاحمر
فادي نعم هناك قلق متواصل في البنتاغون
زين بشان تطورات في البحر الاحمر مع
استمرار هجمات الحوثيين انصار الله
الحوثيين على السفن التي يقولون انها
متجهه الى اسرائيل وخصوصا ان اليوم مصدر
دفاعي امريكي اكد للجزيره انهم يتابعون
تقارير حول وقوع حادثه في البحر الاحمر
وما اشار اليه مصدر عسكري يمني للجزيره
بان هناك سفينه تعرضت للهجوم المتحدث باسم
البنتاغون نفى بعض التصريحات سياسيه هنا
من معارضي الاداره الامريكيه بان الولايات
المتحده تحت اداره بايدن تتعامل بضعف مع
تهديدات الحوثيين وهو اشار الى انه اولا
البنتاجون يتخذ اجراءات من خلال القوات
الامريكيه تحديدا من خلال عمليه ما يسمى
بحارس الازدهار في البحر الاحمر والتي تضم
الان نحو 22 دوله علما ان فقط ثلاثه دول
تساهم بشكل عسكري فيها من خلال وجود خمسه
سفن في جنوب البحر الاحمر وهي عائده
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا ولكن
قال ان هذا الوجود البحري العسكري عمليا
من خلال هذا الوجود يعزز الردع من اجل
حمايه التجاره الدوليه والبحاره على متن
هذه السفن بحكم ان البنتاغون يعتبر بان ما
يقوم به الحوثيون يهدد الجميع جميع السفن
التي تعبر في تلك المنطقه وهو ذكر بالبيان
الذي صدر قبل مده عن الولايات المتحده
وعدد من شركائها الذي اشار الى وجود انه
سوف يكون هناك عواقب في حال استمر
الحوثيون بهجمات هذه المره اعتبر المتحدث
باسم البنتاغون ان هذا البيان كان تحذيرا
موجها للحوثيين ورفض الخوض فيما سماها
التكهنات بما يمكن ان تقوم به الولايات
المتحده للرد على هذه الهجمات ولكنه اشار
انه ينبغي على انصار الله الحوثييين ان
ياخذوا هذا التحذير على محمل الجد
البنتاجون كان اوضح بان اي اجراء عسكري
يتجاوز العمل الدفاعي لحمايه السفن
العابره في تلك المنطقه في خليج عدن وجنوب
البحر الاحمر بطبيعه الحال مضيق باب
المندب هي مجرد اجراءات دفاعيه لا تتجاوز
هذا الامر لكن البنتاجون كان اشار بانه في
حال اتخذ قرار باتخاذ اجراءات عسكريه
مباشره ضد مواقع انصار الله الحوثيين في
اليمن فان ذلك سوف يتم خارج هذا الاطار
التحالفين بمعنى ان الولايات المتحده قد
تتخذ هذه الاجراءات منفرده او مع شركائها
ولكن من خارج هذا الاطار الذي ق الولايات
المتحده انه يمثل تحالفا دوليا فادي منصور
من البنتاجون شكرا
لك